welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Loki season 2 introduces a new
way to feel pain in the MCU and it's not
watching the secret division finale it's
a phenomenon called time slipping
time slipping wait
times you know that yeah you've seen
that yeah can you fix that no
it's impossible to time slipping the TVA
time slipping something that when you
take it frame by frame looks especially
disgusting Loki stretches his hands up
in front of his face causing them to tug
away from his arms down to the sides
like hardened bubble gum stuck to a
sidewalk then when he twists into
nothingness he reappears and for a
single frame you can see his face
contorted in a way that his right
eyeball is exposed in his red eye socket
and then a single frame later his head
splits in half so that his screaming
mouth is a foot lower and his furrowed
brow is somewhere else next when we see
Loki time slipping in the time theater
for a few frames he does the Neo Matrix
bullet Dodge pose until he's taken to a
jet ski parking lot where an inflatable
balloon man is downright bullying him so
what is time slipping well this trailer
starts to give us a definition but to
the exact definition of time slipping in
the context of the broader MCU is a
concept that requires further Insight
especially when we try to compare it to
the glitching we see in the spider-verse
movies so in this video I'm gonna
explain what it really is because the
answer to that question really Define
finds what exactly Loki is all about
quick reminder that sag-aftra has
informed us that entertainment
journalists like new rockstars are
allowed to cover movies and TV shows but
we support the actors and writers in
their strike We join their call to the
amptp to return to the table and reach a
fair agreement okay so right away I
think many people's first instinct when
time slipping is that it's essentially
the glitching effect that characters
experience in Spider-Man into the
spider-verse and Spider-Man across the
spider-verse in which Peter B Parker and
the others in the first film and then
Miles Morales in the second film spasm
and contort whenever they're in the
wrong Universe there is something
similar going on with Loki here but it
is not the same thing because Loki
explains in this trailer I've been
pulled through time
between the past and the present if what
I saw is true there's nothing to stand
between this world and utter destruction
ah and this brings up a key distinction
between the two fundamental categories
of time travel and Multiverse travel
that we've seen so far in the MCU one
vertical forwards in backwards
displacement along a single timeline and
two lateral Multiverse hopping across
different timelines or branches or
universes so time slipping is the first
type in which someone moves forward and
backward along a single timeline
backwards and forwards in time unstuck
from the present and shifting to the
past or to the Future by accident and
one's body's struggling to keep up with
that Kamala Khan did a less sticky
version of this in Ms Marvel using her
Bengal to open a rift in space-time to
revisit the night of the partition in my
interview with Iman villani she did
confirm that Kama going back in time was
part of Kang's plan Doctor Strange did a
cleaner version of this in Avengers
Infinity War using the time Stone to
look ahead to the future but he did
reach to Nexus point where it could go
in 14 million 605 different paths but
because Doctor Strange is the time Stone
and was in a state of practice
meditation there there really was no
stickiness about it in general using the
time Stone allows for smooth time
drifting like this rewinding the bites
of an apple or the destruction of the
Mind Stone and vision's forehead by
Wanda maximoff but time slipping as Loki
experiences it is kind of like walking
along an icy sidewalk and losing your
footing stepping forward a few steps or
falling backward a few steps and yeah
it's painful it's awkward but you're
still on the same sidewalk path so the
second category is glitching as we're
gonna call it here and that refers to
when your body is completely out of sync
from your timeline path and syncs with
your body in another timeline or
universe or Branch this happens to Miles
Morales when he's in Earth 42 at the end
of across the spiderverse and any other
time someone glitches in these movies
we're talking multiple different
sidewalks here a more controlled version
of glitching would be what Multiverse of
Madness called dreamwalking in which one
to maximoff and Doctor Strange
transferred their consciousnesses into
the bodies of their variants in other
universes I've often wondered if the
powers of avastar AKA ghost in the MCU
which were recently exhibited by the
scroll Gaia in the secret Vision finale
along with every other goddamn MCU power
set but that phase shifting might be
ghost glitching in a sense into
alternate timelines or universes of
herself only because she got that power
from Quantum energy and Bill Foster in
that same movie lectured about how
Quantum particles exist in multiple
parallel realities now you don't have to
be Force sensitive to know that if
you're spending all day in the kitchen
You're Gonna Want an apron to keep your
clothes clean and if you're a Star Wars
fan that means you're gonna want one
from Hedley and Bennett Star Wars
collection Henley and Bennett's Star
Wars collector's pizza box comes with
four essential aprons Boba Fett Darth
Vader Luke Skywalker and R2D2 the Box
features art inspired by classic Star
Wars comics from the 1970s a limited
edition sticker and a blue milk recipe
card here is an apron that I got from
these guys oh man oh man look I can fit
my phone right in there hell yeah bro
the details on on these aprons are
awesome the Boba Fett apron has his
sigil in a mythosar skull Luke
Skywalker's apron feels like his X-Wing
flight suit the R2D2 apron has a status
indicator and the Darth Vader apron
makes me feel like an imperial short
order cook it's great and to celebrate
the 40th anniversary of Return of the
Jedi Headley and Bennett also designed a
special edition Galactic Fleet apron and
this hyperspace towel set with the
lucasfilm team the Super Fan bundle
includes the entire Star Wars Headland
Bennett collection so click the link in
the description or go to Headley and
bennett.com and use code new rockstars15
to get 15 off your first order so again
to use the sidewalk metaphor here
glitching would be like walking down a
sidewalk and then realizing you were
simultaneously walking down the sidewalk
on the other side of the street so time
slipping one sidewalk slipping forward
backward on glitching multiple sidewalks
teleporting back and forth across them
this distinction is so important because
despite Loki being a Multiverse Story
the finale of Loki season 1 clearly
redefined it as a story about
predestination on one timeline even the
events that were supposed to have taken
place outside of time itself like in
time neutral zones like the TVA or in
the void or in he who remains Citadel he
remains revealed all of these things all
of these moments were written out in his
transcript he remains planned for Loki
and silby to reach him in that Citadel
so the very Act of Loki and Sylvie
meeting each other across the Multiverse
happened on one timeline that he remains
dictated encompassing all of these
variant branches so despite time
slipping not supposed to be possible
inside of the TBA since the TBA is
actually a facade created by a Kang
variant to exercise control and since
time still flows normally inside of the
TVA on that Kang's timeline things like
slipping forward and slipping backward
inside of that timeline are possible
Loki is currently unstuck from his
position in time not because he's
glitching with other Loki's in other
timelines but because he's just falling
forward a few seconds later or falling
backward a few seconds prior and that
delay pain painfully stretches his body
to catch up to it so to apply some
Destiny logic to Loki's time slipping at
the repairs and advancements desk with
kiwi Kwan he was destined to raise his
hands in that defensive gesture to brace
against the time slipping that would
happen and he was destined to retract
his head in pain and those reactions
caused his body to contort sharply to
where he was destined to go he jolts
because in the future he reacts to
jolting it's a closed loop but really
this is just a way of saying if Loki
could accept the fact that he's
temporarily unstuck in time and that
he's time slipping and just stays still
and move only with intent that slippage
won't be as violent this is the lesson
learned by characters like Billy Pilgrim
and Kurt vonnegut's slaughterhouse 5 or
Desmond Hume and lost two other famous
characters who become unstuck in time
like this they just have to breathe calm
down and accept that their
consciousnesses are just gonna jump
forward and backward to random points on
their lifelines and just sit back and
enjoy the ride actually for Desmond this
process slowly kills him until he
finally studies out with his constant
penne in LA best episode the constant
and I bring up the constant because
something similar may be occurring
between Loki and his constant Sylvie
whose world we see in this trailer
inside of a record store also seems to
be unraveling from her point of view
their time slippage may be a linked
phenomenon that can only be cured when
these two multiversal dance Partners
reunite let me know what you think is
going on here and subscribe to all three
channels of the new rockstars Network
the main Channel The Deep dive and the
break room you can follow me on all
social platforms at eat avos thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
thank you